- [Instructor] Kangaroos can jump
up to three times their height
and they can't walk backward.
Well the way that it's phrased right now
feels a little bit
like, a little bit weird
'cause it's saying kangaroos can jump
up to three times their height.
Well that's an impressive thing
and then they're saying and
they can't walk backward
which is like, okay, they're
listing another thing
but this is more of a,
this is like a limitation
'cause you're like, whoa, most animals
know how to walk backwards.
Very few can jump three times their height
but most can walk backward,
so this actually kind of feels like
it's listing something impressive
but then they're saying,
but they can't do everything awesome.
That they do have limitations.
So, I don't like the use of and here.
And kind of puts them as comparable things
and they're really not.
One is something impressive
and then I would expect something like
a but they can't do something
that everyone else can do.
So, I'm not liking no change.
Let's see, this one is kangaroos can jump
up to three times their height
meaning they can't walk backward.
Well, that doesn't make any sense at all.
Because you jump three times your height
doesn't mean you can't walk backwards.
Kangaroos can jump up to
three times their height
but they can't walk backward.
Well, that feels right because
you're listing something
very impressive but then
you're saying well look,
they can't do everything awesome
but they can't walk backward.
They can't do what normal, a
lot of other animals can do.
Let's look at this last one.
Kangaroos can jump up to
three times their height
since they can't walk backward.
Well, not being able to walk backwards
doesn't allow you to jump up high
so this just doesn't
make any sense either.